ANDREA BUEHLER: My
name is Andrea Buehler.
JEREMY BLAIR: My
name's Jeremy Blair.
MICHAEL THOMAS:
I'm Michael Thomas,
and we're Team PH2OG Water.
JEREMY BLAIR: PH2OG Water
is a premium bottled water
brand that's
looking to challenge
every perception of
what bottled water is.
It's 3 things-- a new source,
environmentally sustainable
packaging, and a social mission.
-We're looking to get our water
from cloud harvesting, which
is a non-groundwater
source, and addresses
the issues of groundwater
depletion and groundwater
pollution that are affecting
a lot of the developed
and developing world.
All that has to happen is
for suspended water droplets
in the air to come in contact
with our cloud harvesting nets,
coalesce into larger
droplets, and then run
into a collection trough.
From there, the water is
piped to a treatment facility,
filtered, sterilized, and
then put into bottles.
It's a non-invasive,
passive technique
with less of a risk
for contamination
than spring or well water.
-This project developed in a
social entrepreneurship class
that was taught at
Princeton University, where
Michael and I developed a
business plan to target people
in water-scarce regions,
with the cloud harvesting
technology.
But what we realized is that
another way to the issue
would be to make a premium
product that puts a profit
pledge on every bottle
sold, to partner
with humanitarian
organizations that
already have feet on the ground.
MICHAEL THOMAS: I
was actually born
on the island of St.
Vincent and the Grenadines,
but my family moved to New
York when I was very young.
After going to Princeton,
and growing up in New York,
I always knew that I wanted
to give back to that place
that I came from.
-So while we were developing
our business plan,
I realized that St.
Vincent had some
of the perfect conditions
for cloud harvest there.
So we took a trip
down there this summer
to set up a pilot site.
Whenever we told
somebody about our idea,
they were incredibly
excited about it,
and they were really
proud that we'd
be able to be going
forward with this.
-The biggest
challenge on the trip
was definitely hiking up
the volcano, La Soufriere.
So when we told
people that we were
gonna do this in the first
place, they were like,
what are you talking about?
You're gonna hike up there
-- all the way up to the top?
We're like, yes, that's
what we're gonna do.
And then we told
them that we were
gonna do it twice in 1 week,
and they just laughed at us.
-But again, it was really
rewarding coming out
of the Palm Break, which is what
they call one of the climates,
and seeing all the clouds
around us-- seeing the fog
--and just how perfect it
was for cloud harvesting.
It was just a really
exciting moment.
And then being able to
finally put up our net,
and see it standing there,
already collecting water
pretty much as soon
as we put it up--
that was an amazing experience.
-Then coming back to Soufriere
the second time-- First of all,
we didn't know if
our cloud harvesting
net was gonna be standing
when we got up there.
We weren't really sure
that that was gonna happen.
So we came up, we
saw it standing
in the first place,
which was like, yeah,
mission accomplished,
number one.
-But then we really
wanted to know
how much water it
can actually get.
So Jeremy runs over to
the cloud harvesting net,
he sees the tank there,and
he goes, it's overflowing!
That was indescribable
happiness at that point.
Just to see that not only
was it a really great site,
but it far surpassed
expectations
in terms of how much
water we can actually get.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING]